(Aplausos)
El sueño.
Nos toma la tercera parte de la vida,
pero ¿alguno de nosotros entiende de qué se trata?
Hace dos mil años, Galeno de Pérgamo,
uno de los más eminentes investigadores médicos
del mundo antiguo,
postuló que mientras estamos despiertos
la fuerza motora del cerebro, su jugo,
se iría a las otras partes del cuerpo
animándolas, pero dejando seco el cerebro.
Pensaba que cuando dormimos
toda la humedad que bañaba el resto del cuerpo
regresaría rápidamente
para hidratar el cerebro
y refrescar la mente.
Ahora esto nos suena ridículo,
pero él estaba simplemente explicando
algo sobre el sueño
que todos experimentamos cada día.
Todos sabemos, por propia experiencia,
que cuando dormimos, la mente se aclara.
Y si no dormimos,
la mente queda turbia.
Pero aunque ahora sabemos mucho más sobre el sueño
que en tiempos de Galeno,
todavía no entendemos por qué razón, el sueño,
de todas nuestras actividades,
tiene esta increíble función restauradora para la mente.
Ahora quiero contarles
de unas recientes investigaciones
que pueden aclarar esta cuestión.
Se ha descubierto que el sueño puede ser, en realidad,
una forma de solución con diseño bien elegante,
para unas de las necesidades más básicas del cerebro,
una forma única por la que este
encuentra las grandes demandas y los estrechos márgenes
que lo diferencian de los demás órganos del cuerpo.
Casi todo lo observado en biología
puede considerarse como una serie de problemas
y sus correspondientes soluciones.
El primer problema que todo órgano tiene que resolver
es el flujo continuo de nutrientes para alimentar
todas las células del cuerpo.
Esto es crítico en el cerebro;
la intensa actividad eléctrica utiliza
la cuarta parte de la energía disponible para el cuerpo,
a pesar de que su masa
representa apenas el 2 % del total.
El sistema circulatorio
resuelve el problema del transporte de nutrientes,
con los vasos sanguíneos distribuyéndolos,
junto con oxígeno, a todos los rincones del cuerpo.
Aquí, en este video, se puede ver esto.
Se muestran los vasos sanguíneos
del cerebro de un ratón vivo.
Esas venas y arterias forman una red compleja
que abarca todo el volumen del cerebro.
Comienzan en la superficie,
se profundiza en los tejidos
y al esparcirse, alimentan de nutrientes
y oxígeno a todas y cada una de las células de este órgano.
Ahora, así como cada célula requiere
de nutrientes para alimentarse,
también produce desperdicios, como subproductos.
La eliminación de desperdicios
es el segundo problema básico
que todos los órganos tienen que resolver.
Este diagrama muestra el sistema linfático del cuerpo
que ha evolucionado para cubrir esta necesidad.
Es otro complejo sistema paralelo de vasos
que se extiende por todo el cuerpo.
Toma las proteínas y otros desechos,
de los espacios entre las células.
Lo que recoge, luego lo deposita en la sangre
para eliminarlo.
Pero al mirar con cuidado el diagrama
se ve algo que
no tiene mucho sentido.
Si se amplía la imagen de la cabeza de este personaje,
se nota que
no hay vasos linfáticos en el cerebro.
Pero esto no tiene mucho sentido, ¿cierto?
El cerebro es un órgano de actividad bien intensa, que produce,
por tanto, gran cantidad de desperdicios,
que hay que eliminar con eficiencia.
Pero carece de vasos linfáticos, lo que significa
que el método utilizado por el resto
del cuerpo para limpiar los desechos,
no funciona en el cerebro.
Entonces, ¿cómo hace el cerebro para resolver
su problema de eliminación de desperdicios?
Pues esta pregunta, aparentemente tan banal,
es a donde llegó nuestro grupo de investigación.
Hemos encontrado
que al adentrarnos en el cerebro,
entre las neuronas y los vasos sanguíneos,
estaba la solución
al problema de la limpieza de los residuos.
Algo verdaderamente inesperado.
Ingenioso, pero también hermoso.
Permítanme que les cuente lo que descubrimos.
El cerebro cuenta con esta gran reserva
de fluido limpio y transparente, llamado líquido cefalorraquídeo
o también LCR [CSF].
El líquido cefalorraquídeo llena el espacio que rodea el cerebro
y ahí llegan los desperdicios
provenientes del interior del cerebro.
para, líquido y desechos, ser vertidos al torrente sanguíneo.
Dicho de esta manera,
suena como el sistema linfático, ¿correcto?
Lo interesante es que el líquido y los desechos
del interior del cerebro
no se cuelan al azar para
llegar a los depósitos de LCR.
Lo que sucede es que hay un sistema de plomería especializado
que organiza y facilita el proceso.
Eso se puede ver en estos videos.
De nuevo, esta es una imagen del cerebro
de un ratón vivo.
El cuadro a la izquierda muestra
lo que sucede en la superficie del cerebro
y a la derecha se ve lo que pasa por debajo,
en el interior de los tejidos.
Se muestran los vasos sanguíneos en rojo
y el LCR que rodea al cerebro está en verde.
Lo que nos sorprendió
es que el líquido del exterior del cerebro
no se queda en la superficie.
En cambio, ese LCR es impulsado
por todo el interior del cerebro,
por la periferia de los vasos sanguíneos,
Al circular por dentro del cerebro
por la superficie de los vasos,
ayuda a despejar y a limpiar de excesos,
los espacios entre células cerebrales.
Si lo piensan,
usar de esta manera el exterior
de los vasos sanguíneos es una solución con brillante diseño,
porque el cerebro está encerrado
en el cráneo rígido, lleno por completo de células,
sin espacio disponible para
otro sistema de vasos,
como el linfático.
Los vasos sanguíneos descienden desde la superficie hasta llegar
a cada una de las células del cerebro ,
lo cual quiere decir que el líquido
que circula por el exterior de los vasos
tiene fácil acceso a toda la masa cerebral.
En verdad es un sistema genial
este de readaptar un sistema de vasos, el sanguíneo,
para que asuma la función y reemplace
a un segundo sistema de vasos, el linfático.
hasta hacerlo innecesario.
Lo interesante es que no hay ningún otro órgano
que asuma este enfoque,
para eliminar los desechos de entre las células.
Es una solución absolutamente única.
Pero el hallazgo más sorprendente es que todo esto,
todo lo que he venido explicando,
lo del líquido pasando por el cerebro,
solo sucede en el cerebro dormido.
El video a la izquierda muestra
qué tanto circula el líquido cefalorraquídeo
por el cerebro de un ratón vivo, estando despierto,
casi nada.
Pero con el mismo animal,
si esperamos un poco a que se duerma,
se ve una estampida del LCR por todo el cerebro.
Al mismo tiempo descubrimos
que cuando se duerme el cerebro
sus células parecen reducirse
abriendo espacios entre unas y otras
para permitir que el líquido pase libremente
y así se eliminen los desperdicios.
Parece como si Galeno se hubiese aproximado
a la pista correcta, cuando escribió
que el fluido circulaba hacia el cerebro
durante el sueño.
Nuestras investigaciones,
2000 años más tarde,
sugieren que el cerebro despierto,
cuando está más atareado,
pospone la eliminación de los desechos
de los espacios intercelulares,
para más tarde y, luego, cuando duerme,
y no está tan ocupado,
hace el cambio hacia la función de limpieza para sacar los desperdicios
que se habían acumulado durante el día.
Es algo semejante a lo que hacemos nosotros;
posponemos las tareas de casa durante la semana,
cuando no hay tiempo para eso
y luego nos ponemos al día
con toda la limpieza, en el fin de semana.
He hablado bastante de la eliminación de desechos,
pero no he especificado
qué clase de desechos
son los que el cerebro necesita eliminar
durante el sueño para mantenerse saludable.
Esos estudios recientes sobre los desechos
se han concentrado principalmente
en beta amiloide
que es una proteína que se produce en el cerebro todo el tiempo.
Mi cerebro, como el de Uds.,
está produciendo beta amiloide ahora mismo.
Pero en pacientes con la enfermedad de Alzheimer,
se añade y se acumula beta amiloide
en los espacios intercelulares del cerebro
en lugar de eliminarse, como debiera.
Esa acumulación de beta amiloide,
se piensa que es una de las etapas cruciales
en el desarrollo de esa terrible enfermedad.
Hemos medido cuán rápido se elimina el beta amiloide
del cerebro cuando está despierto,
versus cuando duerme,
y encontramos que, en realidad,
la eliminación del beta amiloide
es mucho más rápida con el cerebro dormido.
Entonces, si el sueño
es parte de la solución
del problema de la eliminación de residuos
entonces esto cambia dramáticamente
nuestra idea sobre la relación entre el sueño, el beta amiloide
y la enfermedad de Alzheimer.
Unos estudios clínicos recientes
sugieren que en los pacientes
que no han desarrollado la enfermedad,
el deterioro de la calidad y duración
del sueño, se relacionan con
mayor acumulación de beta amiloide en el cerebro.
Es importante señalar que estos estudios
no demuestran que la carencia
o escasez de sueño sean causa de la enfermedad de Alzheimer.
Pero sí sugieren que la falla del cerebro
en mantener la casa limpia
con la limpieza de los residuos como el beta amiloide
puede contribuir al desarrollo
de ciertas condiciones, como el Alzheimer.
Entonces, lo que nos dicen
estas investigaciones es algo que todos
ya sabíamos sobre el sueño.
Hasta Galeno entendía bien
que refresca y aclara la mente.
Esto puede ser una parte importante
de la naturaleza del sueño.
Sabemos que todos, Uds. y yo, tenemos que dormir
todas las noches, pero el cerebro nunca descansa.
Mientras el cuerpo está quieto
la mente está andando por ahí, en sueños,
la elegante maquinaria del cerebro
silenciosamente sigue trabajando,
haciendo limpieza y mantenimiento
a esta máquina tan increíblemente compleja.
Como las tareas de casa, se trata
de trabajos sucios y desagradecidos,
pero también muy importantes.
En la casa, si dejamos de limpiar la cocina
durante un mes,
la casa se vuelve completamente invivible
muy rápidamente.
En el cerebro, las consecuencias
de atrasarse pueden ser mucho peores
que la vergüenza de muebles sucios,
porque al referirse al cerebro,
es la salud misma y las funciones
de la mente y el cuerpo, lo que está en juego.
Por esta razón,
entender bien estas funciones tan básicas
de la limpieza del cerebro, hoy,
puede ser crucial para la prevención y el tratamiento
de las enfermedades mentales del mañana.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)